this morning on a special edition of the
dish we look at a new take on Mexican
food from an acclaimed New York
restaurant Enrique O'Mara had already
made his mark with Puyol his Mexico City
eatery that became a dining destination
I got to go there Thank You husband now
at new york's Cosme he and chef Daniella
salinas blend Mexican flavors with local
and seasonal ingredients for an
experience that is redefining our image
of Mexican food a very lucky Michelle
Miller paid them a visit
do you understand chef Danielle Soto in
it so you wanna pull the face of the
scallop down right you must make the
rounds in her kitchen
a fast-paced production line it's a
formula that works when you have high
energy and when you have passion moving
to a beat that feeds a myriad of palates
it all fits together for this twenty
nine-year-old Mexico City native who
believes that everyone in her domain as
the potential to run the show is amazing
to see that they can have a chance to
run their own kitchens you see the
tortilla ladies I don't think you go to
any kitchen in America and see this many
women in it
they're badasses they're amazing
she's said it not me sorry that ability
to see promise has come full circle
because world-renowned chef Enrique
Olvera saw it in her what was it about
her that impressed you Daniela was it's
always been really high energy I think
she also knows how to belong to the team
but also command a team which is the
heart for chef's to understand after a
chance meeting in New York he invited
her to apprentice with him in Mexico
City
his signature restaurant that was ranked
the best in North America a few years
later he hand-picked her to partner and
run his first New York venture this
restaurant Cosme seen enormous success
is that part of the secret the diversity
happiness the mixture of happiness and
hard work and fun Lachie Keyes is the
best dancer that you ever see playing
host is something both have taken too
whether throwing their customers a
five-year anniversary party were simply
seating President Obama and the first
lady in 2016 even if neither chefs were
there in person my knees was being
burned were you here
I wasn't Mexico luckily their third
partner restaurateur Santiago Perez was
I was called to the front of the
restaurant and they very polite they
asked me late would you have the private
dining room available and the guy gives
me the business card and it's Secret
Service did it click then it kind of it
wasn't immediate you know I wasn't
expecting it what did they think they
loved it and that visit came before
Cosme was named the best eatery in the
US on the world's 50 best restaurants
list for their own unique take on their
hometown food we have razor clams but we
caught it to make that what this duo
seems to have accomplished mixing it up
while keeping it true I mean you're a
classically trained chef and yet you say
most of what you apply in that kitchen
comes from your grandmother's kitchen I
think we all cook from memory and then
you can't create something that you
don't cherish I think it's important for
us to as cooks to understand who we are
I was trained in New York and when I
came back to Mexico I realized I didn't
know much about my own country and
little by little we got to know our own
cuisines all the regional cuisines of
Mexico and we literally fell in love and
true Mexican cuisine is what fuels their
menu you see five similar things which
is the agave corn beans pumpkin pumpkin
chiles and on and on but we wanted to
showcase Mexican food in New York using
the same idea that we use in Mexico it's
like taking a bath consider this dish
sea bass with it scales fry like Chitra
doll
[Music]
I love this dressed with Moho salsa
drizzle it make it nice and green oh
it's gorgeous yes I don't usually like
scales but oh well did you try this one
mm-hmm
the sauce is everything I do okay what
else do we have here or arctic char in a
tumeric ginger and sea buckthorn sauce
and sea buckthorn is so good for your
skin mmm this is so light it's so not
what people think of when they think of
Mexican when you come to eat it cause
many if you see we like to have things
that are vibrant and and fresh we want
you to come out of the restaurant
feeling happy and alive instead of over
wand and yes loaded
[Music]
now that the duel is conquered New York
Los Angeles is next the recipe for
success they say is simple if you don't
enjoy it you can't persevere just find a
good mentor that will elevate you and
will compliment you and you will learn
nonstop learning non-stop and seeing the
results is really nice
I think Michelle should take us there
it's a done deal
done deal look out here she can't even
vote yes right
you